diana amft eine der top schauspielerin
in deutschland jetzt in frisch gepresst
aktuell im kino und sie hatte ja einen
sehr schweren anfang sie anfang habe ich
schon gesagt
sie wurde in zahlreichen
schauspielschule abgelehnt warum ist
dann trotzdem geschafft hat das jetzt im
talk und natürlich noch viel mehr
die lage schon hier draußen das schön
auf jene studios entspannt waren die
dreharbeiten auch entspannt die waren
auch entspannter zu da ist dann bist du
natürlich noch mal mehr angebote nicht
das gefühl gehabt jetzt hier so ein
bisschen spontan improvisiert hatte
tallec außerdem einzelsitzen fünf
minuten später dann woanders
aber wir müssen ja immer gucken wie ist
die lage wo können wir uns aufbauen und
beim filmset ist das für alles - von
gesetzen locations und kann er nicht so
spontan umdisponieren
hast du das ist ja ein buch von susanne
fröhlich um was mir aufgefallen ist
du siehst ihr in jüngeren jahren also
meint sofort irgendwie kriegt man das
zusammen hast du dich auch so gefühlt
wie sie oder hat das kann dann gar
nichts miteinander zu tun
du meinst mit susanne fröhlichkeit damit
ihre position nicht aber oder hat ja
wenn man den film sieht denkt man das
hängt irgendwie alles zusammen wir haben
parallel dass wir gleich beide blonde
locken haben aber ansonsten das ist ja
dann wenn frau fröhlich beantworten
diese frage weil ich weiß ja nicht wie
sie so vielleicht immer dabei wurde auch
das ist da irgendwas autobiografisches
entdeckt wie sie es wie sie das buch
mein darüber geschrieben hat ich glaube
das kann ich nicht für sie verantworten
dass nicht du hast nicht mit ihr
gesprochen
der richter nicht aber interessant werde
ich gleich ansprechen
ok muss ich noch mal wieder bekommt man
nicht auf die idee wenn man sich da so
sieht und denkt dass es eher so aus wie
sie und meine du bist ja auch sie hat es
ja auch eine dunkelhaarige oder sonstwie
ja ich glaube das kann leicht aus zufall
seiner seite wie beide blond ist aber
wer weiß wie sie aussah
also ich weiß ich genau was er will
gemeinde und ich finde es auch über
china also wenn man beim aber ich
schätze autoren immer sehr und ich finds
immer schwierig dass man sagt ja du hast
doch bestimmt jetzt soweit ich
geschrieben und subtropischen seine
geschichte und wenn ich darf das ja
gleich weiter obwohl ich ja schon so
unterschiedliche sachen geschrieben
inwieweit da überhaupt jetzt so
autobiografisches einfluss aber wie
gesagt es kann sicher besser antwort
natürlich okay aber hast du dich
unabhängig davon da drin wohl gefühlt in
dem was da passiert ja absolut beides
von anfang eine figur mit der ich mich
sehr gut identifizieren konnte ich finde
es steht einfach irgendwie so dies ja so
curtis samstag ist also was sie so mein
alter und ich finde sie steht ein
gesunder heutigen zeit für unsere
generation also zwischen ja weiß ich
nicht fängt so an mit anfang dreißig
dass man so große riesige entscheidung
auf ihn zu kommen so zusammen zehn
jahren ein kinder ja nein beruf karriere
was mache ich
und deswegen kann ich mich da sehr
schnell mit identifizieren
aber bei ihr ist ja oder bei der rolle
ist ja und ich glaube dass wir die etwas
anders so ziemlich alles schief gelaufen
diesen im laden der kurz vor der pleite
steht darf jetzt nicht zu viel verraten
also ist es irgendwie nicht so toll bei
ihr ja anders irgendwie anders aber ich
meine da schon eigentlich karriere
eigentlich hat sie ziemlich gute
aussichten sogar international letzten
weg zu gehen und der wird halt einfach
irgendwie plötzlich wird das ganze leben
auf den kopf gestellt ich durch
ereignisse bestimmte umstände okay wenn
du dich damit identifiziert kommt dass
mit der vorbereitung auf die rolle
oder ist das wenn du so ein buch liest
das buch da mache ich gerne mit der
identifizierung mich und das buch das
mache ich nicht so gerne ihren beziehe
ich mich oder lebst du dich rein wie
beides also ich muß schon irgendwie so
einen ersten zugang sofort haben sonst
macht es keinen sinn die rolle nicht
verstehen oder wenn ich keine ahnung ich
verstehe die jetzt nicht ich weiß jetzt
nicht ihre motivation also ich muss die
muss schon irgendwie für mich
eine lebendigkeit haben wo ich sagte ja
das ist das ist realistisch und das kann
ich auch nachvollziehen auch wenn es auf
ganz anderen ebene ist das ist da dass
es dem alter probleme zu lösen gibt und
man sich gewisse fragen stellt und das
war als dort sofort gegeben und alles
weitere kommt dann natürlich mit der
vorbereitung also dass man sich dann
versucht da noch mehr in die figur
hinein zu fühlen und sich irgendwie ganz
genau überlegt wie muss man sich jetzt
in der situation fühlen wenn man
irgendwie das und das verloren hat und
die un entscheidung auf ihn zukommen wo
hast du dich wieder gefunden in der
figur einfach da dass man dass man dass
man schon auch irgendwie nicht immer
ganz genau weiß ob das jetzt richtig ist
oder falsch dass es so ist wirklich
entscheidungen im leben gibt die so
unglaublich stark die zukunft
beeinflussen und die angst auch davor zu
haben diese entscheidung zu treffen also
dass das fand ich schon echt da ist
einfach was dran und wenn man irgendwie
jetzt schwanger oder wie andrea
ungewollt schwanger ist es klar dass man
eine mega-party schiebt deswegen so mit
geburt des kindes hassen komplett
anderes leben
wie machst du es bei solchen
entscheidung mainz die male wo ich wann
aber und so und riechen und schmecken
aber wusste entscheidung geht de
also ich finde halt ich hab mir jetzt so
ein credo gesagt habe ich gedacht habe
so wenn man darf jetzt irgendwie es wäre
so schwer wenn man später einen punkt
kommt momentan jetzt hätte ich alles
anders gemacht in die wenn ich jetzt
noch mal die entscheidung treffen können
nicht alles anders gemacht sondern ich
denke man muss einfach akzeptieren
das ist auch wenn es vor zwei jahren war
dass es zu dem zeitpunkt die richtige
entscheidung war und dass man auch immer
wieder zu dem zeitpunkt genau so
entscheiden würde
und es bringt überhaupt nichts zu denken
jetzt wird es anders machen und weil man
hat es ja nicht anders gemacht und zu
dem zeitpunkt was richtig also soll man
da gar nicht drüber nachdenken
ok also gab es im moment wo du ich hätte
mich vor zwei jahren bisher anders
entschieden
so gab es bestimmt schon also wie gesagt
aber ich habe den letzten jahr wirklich
ganz krass daran gearbeitet dass ich
habe eigentlich recht früh schon damit
angefangen hat diese einstellung zur
arbeit ist okay für irgendwas ist es gut
also zum beispiel damals ich habe
damals bin ich also bei ganz vielen
schauspielschulen durchgefallen
da habe ich schon mal zu dieser
einstellung versucht zu vertreten das
ist für irgendwas ist gut auch wenn ich
jetzt noch nicht weiß für was weißt du
dir höllisch weh und es könnten auch
keine vorstellung was ist gut sein
sollte sie jetzt dadurch gefallen mit
irgendwas ist gut und wenn es auch jetzt
nicht im halben jahr heraus findet aber
vielleicht in zwei jahren oder drei
jahren dann wirst du schon sehen warum
es so sein sollte und ich weiß nicht
also ich hab bin dann halt irgendwann
gespielt hatten ein zwei jahre später in
münchen einer schauspielschule
angenommen
in der ich in der mir die direktorin
schon die gelegenheit gegeben hat
während des studiums theater spielen zu
dürfen abends dann hab ich gedacht toll
dafür war es jetzt gut hätte ich
vielleicht bei der anderen schule gut
ich wäre vielleicht ein studium schon
fertig aber hätte ich diese praktische
erfahrung vielleicht nicht machen können
oder dürfen
bist du jemand der sich durchbeißt ja
jetzt nicht auf alle gewalten also wenn
jetzt irgendwie also es kommt immer
darauf an
also ich sage es mal so ich bin
stehaufmännchen und aber ich muss jetzt
nicht mit aller gewalt irgendwas
erreichen wenn sie nicht wenn ich merke
keine ahnung dass uns das passt nicht
oder das stimmt nicht oder du kannst
jetzt noch was weiß ich was dafür tun
dass man will nicht dass es so ist dann
nehme ich das auch an und sag ich doch
du willst und versuchte irgendwie mit
allem mitteln weil das bringt ja auch
nichts irgendwas zu erzwingen
also erzwingen würde es nicht aber
ansonsten würde ich schon sagen dass ich
steh auf männchen wenn auch ein
kämpferischer typ
hast du da so denkt auch den kontakt mit
der rolle gefunden die die ist ja
erstmal irgendwie so ihren kopf dann
irgendwie sich einig mit dem schicksal
ja ich find's ganz schön dass ihr da so
ein bisschen
diese entwicklung macht dass sie sich
dann tatsächlich so mehr darauf einlässt
auf die ganze situation und und sie
merkt halt ab dem punkt wo sie so
bisschen drauf einlässt dass plötzlich
auch alles gar nicht mehr so schlimm ist
wie sie dachte und eigentlich auch ganz
schön wird deswegen sollte man sich den
film angucken spannend ok wunder
bauausschuss wird also wenn euch dieser
talk mit diana amft gefallen hat dann
schaut euch auch den letzten mit
commander krieger an in dem er darüber
erzählt wie er sich in seiner heftigsten
video tierisch ausgeholt hat als er über
den tod seiner mutter gesprochen hat
lust sich dagegen der mit nora tschirner
sie erzählt nämlich dass sich zuweilen
ihren freund heftig beschimpft wie das
kommt und wie er darauf reagiert dass im
talk mit nora tschirner also entweder
was ernstes oder was sehr lustiges ihr
könnt jetzt leer